so you mentioned that some of the people
who would have the hardest time or the
humanists i think you mentioned that
well you mentioned it here but i'm using
the word humanist right now christians
believe and they you can see this in the
comments section i'm sure you're aware
of considering the alien beings to be
angels or demons but i'm wondering is
there a third option yes for sure yeah
like what else are there besides angels
and demons yeah so i mean we have exo so
people who are doing like looking at
habitable planets like exoplanets and
things like that you know these are
straight-up scientists who are doing
this work and they're out there just
finding out if there's habitable planets
or life out there even and i think that
that's the way to look at it i think
that that has nothing to do with the
idea of these are angels or demons we're
just looking for
potential
planets that have even moons or even
asteroids that have you know life on
them and i think that that's a
scientific endeavor and that has really
nothing to do with religion whatsoever
it just has to do with exploration you
know and that's what we're doing you
know we're kind of an exploratory
species and we're now heading out into
space and exploring that and that's the
third option